Mìo tại buổi lắm việc, thu tướng đề nghị tình tiếp tục quán triệt, cập nhật và quyết liệt trên 2 độc bộ
nhiều quả các nghị quyết, kết lộn của chúng hơn 1 chiến trị bản biệt thương của hội chính phủ.
thu tướng yêu cầu tình lặng sơn và quyết liệt thực hiện kịch bản tăng trường trong sâu tháng của năm.
Lãnh đạo tình cần theo rồi sát, luôn đốc việc thực hiện các nhận vụ, để quyết tâm phân đấu cả năm hoàn thành một
bíu tăng trường gờ đếp bê từ mời phần trăm trở lên. Người đứng đầu chính phủ nhấn mạnh, tân xác định gió môi hình tăng trường
của hợp với lợi thế đặc thủ của tình bến dưới. Tập trung một lực yếu tiến phát triển kịch tế cơ khẩu,
thương mại lộsistic minh mầu. Nhưng kỳ u đề xuất cách một hình kịch tế mới có tính đột phá như
khu thương mại từ gió, khu hợp tắc kinh tế qua bến dưới, lắm đổ lực giãn giát các hành công nghiệp,
trị cầu, nóng lâm nghiệp hàng hoá phát triển theo chủ ý giá chiếc. Cùng về đó,
lặng sơn cần chương trình khai hợp quả của hạt tình thời gian hiểu của trong hay mốt, khảnh cũng trong bà mời,
tâm dình đến năm hành hiểu trong lâm mời, vừa được phép dưới đều dình. Cụ thể hoá môi hình tổ chức không ra một chục phát triển,
hành lặng tình tế, bà vùng tình tế ra hồi, trong đó tập trung một lực cho chục phát triển đồng đăng dưới lúng,
và vùng tình tế độc lặng với khu tình tế cơ khẩu đồng đăng lặng sơn. Lâm hạt nhân để giãn giát tăng trường của tình.
Nếu gió chính phủ đã thông nhất chủ trường nghiêm cứu phương án thích hợp mốn trình trình tế cơ khu dài nhận này,
thành một trình trình trông, thủ tưởng lưu ý tình và trình bị đầy đủ điều kiện để tiếp nhận,
phân mổ và trình khai ngay khách trình trình tế cơ khu dài. Giá đoạn hành hình trong hài sáo hình của trăm mời sau khi được trung lương ra vốn,
thủ tưởng yêu cơ, vài sư lý rất điểm các giãn chậm tiến độ tôn đồng kéo dài,
nhát là vốn mắt về giải phó mặt bằng, yêu tiên một lực cho không chính hạn thần giá thông trên lượng,
cách nối liên vùng và khúc tế theo của hạt của tình. Về việc của anh hành chính quyền để phương hài cấp,
thủ tưởng một lần nữa nhận mạnh, chúng tôi không có chủ trường sát nhập sát,
phương trên dần dầu, vì vậy tình thành phố cần chủ động ra sát để xuất phương án điều trình đơn vị hành chính cấp sát,
nếu thấy cần thiết, trên cơ sở yêu cầu thực tiến và quy định của pháp luật. Mà khác,
tình lãn sơn cần để mạnh phát triển dù lịch trở thành ngàn kinh tế mối nhỏ theo dưỡng quay tình,
gắn với công viên để chắc phản cầu UNASCO lãn sơn, khu dù lịch cuốc gia mẫu sơn và khác sản phẩm dù lịch biệt giới đặc trơn.
Thủ đưởng lưu ý, phải quan tâm thực hiện tốt chính xác ăn xin xá hội,
y tế giá dục văn hoa, giảm nghe bình bứng, nhát là đối với đồng bảo rất tộc thiệu số, phù vực biệt giới,
chuẩn bị tốt cho năm 2020, hành hành hành hành hành hành hành hành bài, tập trung hành thành bốn trường vổ thông
nổi trú liên cấp, kể công đồ một có kế hoài đưa các trường vào bản hành hệ quả ngay trong năm 2020,
quan tâm thực hiện tốt chính xác đối với người có công thân nhân lệ xí nhé nè, hành bài tháng bài.
Thủ đưởng yêu cầu tiếp tục cùng của Cũng phòng Anh Ninh, giữa vấn chủ quyền biên giới cuốc gia,
bà đam chặt từ Antoàn xá hội, khu vực biên giới, chú đậu tích cực trên khai công tác đối ngoài với tình khoảng tay Trung Quốc,
xây dựng biên giới khoảng bình, kế mi, tắc và phát triển.
Dạ đáp một số đệ xuất của thay của tình, tủ tưởng rao các mộ, các quan điệ phương,
nhưng kế uống nổi dung đề với hợp xử lý chủ đậu, thực hiện các nhận vụ theo thầm quyền,
kì thời báo cáo đệ xuất, cấp có thầm quyền, những bản đề với thầm quyền.
Sáng cùng ngay, tủ tưởng lên mình hương và đoàn công tác đả đến dân quyền,
dân qua tưởng miệm khai hùng lệ xí y tạng nế trang lệ xí lạng sơn.
Trong khổ khi thiên liện xúc đầu, thu tưởng lên mình hương và các bạn biểu đá tưởng miếp và biệt ở nấu xác kài hùng lệ xí.
Trong đỏ, còn những người còn yêu dấu của quay hương lạng sơn, đáyng giữ khi xin,
bị dựng nghiệp nấu tranh giải phóng rao tân tộc, xây dựng và bảo vệ tủ Quốc.
Hãy chào mọi người, tủ tưởng miệm lạng mộ của một phần thông tin, sống miếm mộ trưa sách định được thông tin.
Máo đào của các anh, các chỉ đã tổ tham thêm mộ cơ viên quan của tủ Quốc,
cho đất nước được nửa hoa được lập, kết trải tự gó.
Bụt đưởng lên mình hương và đoàn con tác đã đến thăm ông vi và nước,
xinh nămu nhìn chỉ trăm bộ tâm, là thương bình, tí lệ tổn thương cơ thể bốn miệm hành trăm,
hợp đang xin sống tại khối tâm, phượng đấu kinh.